y vamos ahora en directo a Chile porque
la situación de cerca de 200 personas
que según la acnur son mayoritariamente
venezolanas ha saltado a los titulares
internacionales Naciones Unidas señala
que en muchos casos no tienen recursos
ni alimentos y que las autoridades tanto
de Santiago como de Lima que han
militarizado las fronteras les bloquean
Incluso el retorno a su país conectamos
Ahora sí con Santiago donde está nuestra
corresponsal Patricia Luna Patricia
buenas noches para usted le preguntó
cuáles son las perspectivas para estas
personas
Buenas noches perspectivas poco
halagüeñas por el momento para estas
personas que llevan varias semanas ahí
atrapadas debido a que muchos de ellos
entraron por ese mismo lugar a Chile sin
documentos y una vez en el país les ha
dificultado mucho la posibilidad de
obtener documentación lo que complica a
la vez su capacidad para por ejemplo
obtener trabajo o obtener vivienda para
que les alquilen una vivienda además
muchos de ellos se han visto muy
afectados por el incremento de la del
precio de la vida en el país Esto es lo
que hace que muchos decidan o algunos de
ellos decidan emprender el camino de
vuelta y que se vean atrapados Porque al
no tener documentos la policía peruana
no les deja atravesar el camino de
vuelta caminando para regresar hasta
Venezuela las autoridades chilenas han
propuesto un corredor emigratorio para
poder
volver permitir que estas personas pasen
a través de varios países pero están en
coordinación con distintos en diálogo
con Perú y con otros países para que
esto se haga realidad mientras viven
allá atrapados en condiciones
extremadamente duras las de un desierto
el más salido del mundo donde hace frío
extremo en las noches y mucho calor al
mediodía